Today, I'm going to show you a simple science experiment...
...that you can try at home to learn about density.
Start by taking an empty glass and tip in some water and food coloring.
Then add some syrup or treacle.
And I'm going to add a little bit more water to make the layer a bit thicker.
Then finally, fill the glass up with some oil...
...and leave it to settle for about 15 minutes.
These liquids separate out into different layers...
...because they're different densities and they don't mix.
The syrup has the highest density, so it sits on the bottom...
...and the oil, which has the lowest density, rises to the top.
Try dropping different objects in to see what happens.
If we drop this metal nut in, which is really dense,...
...you can see it sinks right to the bottom.
But if I take this grape and drop it in,...
...it sinks through the oil in water, but sits on the syrup.
This is because the syrup is denser than the grape.
Pretty cool, huh!
Now, if I take this plastic bottle top and drop it in,...
...it slowly sinks through the oil and sits on the water.
And finally, if I take this piece of sponge and drop it in, it sits on top.
The oil is denser than the sponge.
You can try dropping different objects in to see which fluids are denser.
I also found shining a torch beam down from above gives a really nice effect.